scientists have just discovered the
flattest explosion ever and they've
named it the cow the cow is a type of
fast blue Optical transient or f-bot
it's a type of explosion in space much
more powerful than a supernova they're
already a bit of a mystery to scientists
because unlike supernovas they don't
emit radioactive elements and the cow is
even more mysterious because it's
extremely flat we're used to
experiencing spherical explosions but
this one that happened 180 million
kilometers away is more like a pancake
one theory is that this f-bot is a
failed Supernova where instead of
exploding it collapses into a neutron
star or a black hole but why do you
think they call it the cow